ça commence comme un match de foot la
bad les fanions et ça coûte presque
aussi cher aux fidèles à un million de
francs pour ce seul podium car le
bâtiment abrite un ascenseur qui permet
à jean paul 2 d'être au niveau des
familles totalement acquise grâce à ces
petits mots qui font toujours plaisir à
l'âme des inconditionnels
ses amis en passant milliers de vous
c'était une joie de voir un enfant
les robots sont les porte-parole des
familles ils baisseront même la main du
pape au nom des vingt mille personnes
qui sont face à jean paul ii
ils évoqueront aussi de vieilles
histoires de famille j'ai dit que les
familles étaient très très heureuse de
rencontrer
j'ai partagé
cette expérience du parc des princes en
1990 j'avais déjà été la scène des
jeunes aux étudiants gilbert voyage
maintenant père de famille j'étais très
rapide mais je crois que veiller en lui
un bon souvenir que c'est trop con du
paraguay
paris le pape apprécie aussi les petits
robots comme moi ce qui m'a touché aussi
c'est la saison son geste de paternité à
l'égard des filles quand elles sont
allés saluer un début du dîner des
fleurs comment il les a enveloppé
pratiquement il appuyé c'est gagner le
cadeau du pape est adapté il suivra la
croissance des enfants celle de leurs
trois enfants jean paul ii